[Music]
well questions continue to loom as the
investigation continues into a las vegas
newspaper journalist death today a
search of a clark county public
administrator robert tullis's home all
in direct connection to that case so
that happened very early this morning
and throughout the afternoon there's
been a lot of developments and at this
hour there is now a barricade situation
underway so let's get right out to
vanessa murphy with ongoing activity
outside of telus's neighborhood in his
home there near charleston and hualapai
vanessa
at this point we have not heard whether
robert tellis is in custody but i can
tell you this neighborhood is on
lockdown we were evacuated from
a couple of blocks away we had to climb
two ladders
police want to keep that area safe for
the public for police and obviously the
hope would be that robert tellis would
peacefully surrender i'll step out of
the way so you can see the scene here
again this is an active scene now
this is a public administrator robert
tellis police have zeroed in on him in
their homicide investigation the victim
is investigative journalist jeff german
from the review journal gearman had
reported several pieces about telus that
telus was unhappy with but again this is
a very
active scene
many police officers swat they have that
house surrounded we are trying to report
this carefully